hey everyone it's michaelos and welcome
to the orderflows market analysis for
August 8 2017 interesting day uh Market
made new Highs but then it sold off
later in the day on Trump's remarks
about North Korea being uh met with Fe
fire and fury so you know our our rally
up was uh became a selloff later in the
day a brief disclaimer of this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only it should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a Futures Contract or make any
other type of investment decision
Futures training contains stal risk is
not for every
investor investor could potentially lose
more or all of their initial investment
risk capital is money that can be lost
without jeopardizing one's Financial
Security or lifestyle only risk Capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk Capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
results tools I use in this presentation
are the order flows Trader and the Delta
scalper the orderflows trader is the
volume footprint chart the Delta scalper
is a tool that we developed to analyze
the delta in the market um you know it's
actually being used and developed by
some Traders into a full-blown trading
system and I'll show you some charts
with it uh it's it's quite
revealing okay so let's get uh let's
take a look first we'll start in the e-
minis okay so coming into the session
this morning we had a a pretty tight
range you know 7 in the morning you're
looking at uh was at 73 and 1/2 low 77
and 1/2 uh high so basically a fourpoint
range
and you know waiting for the Cash open
to see if we get any type of movement
cash opened we hit these lows here boom
boom boom sorry one new low new low here
then we started this rally now here you
have the Delta scalper right after the
cash open okay did it work out no I I'll
say it didn't um you know the market did
make a new low by about a point just
over a point but you I was talking about
this in the room what was very very
interesting and revealing I I felt was
look at this look at the Delta on the
low right so you know earlier here um
you know just going back to last night
um you know this is 2: in the morning
here this is midnight you it's just it's
all negative Deltas all negative Deltas
then you start coming in you know to
8:00 you know even it's in s you got the
positive Delta you got a negative Delta
here but then positive small positive
positive a negative positive positive
positive positive at this point you know
we're just right around our low still 74
so you're you're hanging down here but
you're seeing net aggressive buying you
know it's almost as if someone is is
there accumulating a position I found
that to be very bearish just you know as
I would find it to be very you know if
you're up here at your high you know
hanging out there for you know 2 hours
and have all basically all net selling
I'd be very bearish but in this case you
know it's all net positive buying you
know positive Delta which is is quite
strong and what happens is the market
starts to Rally boom we get up here here
near this right near the high we got
stack buying in Balance up here this was
77 um you know around 762 to 77 and a
quarter and then no follow through you
know we we come up here poke a new high
by a tick you got a Divergence um no
ratio Delta scalper did give a sell
there which didn't work out now but it
was
very why it didn't work out you know
this bar is very um very revealing
you've got the selling and balance down
here you got a big volume numbers here
,900 1,700 you have negative Delta you
know normally you think oh you got you
know negative Delta of 12200 you know
Mike just told me that you know we're
hanging around the low with uh positive
Delta you know the market should rally
now we're up here near the highs with
negative Delta looking for the market to
sell off but read what's happening in
the bar why do you have negative
Delta it's cuz you got you know you got
bidd bidding in here basically you know
it's in the area where the Stacked
imbalance was so you know you had
aggressive buyers earlier now you know
these buyers are still lingering around
here they're bidding the market and then
you see some more aggressive buying come
in 26583 1724 you you have this split
stacked in Balance over two bars then
you poke higher start poking higher new
High um buying and balance you know each
bars got buying and balances as we're
going higher
now yesterday's high is that yesterday's
high 80 no sorry um 80 and a half was
was contract high this line here he I
don't have yesterday's high this is an
old value area so yesterday's high was
here 78 and a half I felt that if we can
get through this one really quick I I
thought we could make a move up to uh
you know the 80 and a half level which
we did um you know pretty quick boom
making these new
highs Divergence that fails Divergence
that fails but again you know you have
it comes right back with bullish ratio
here um there's no reason to be selling
these
divergences you know you do have three
bars with negative Delta that's not GNA
be enough you know I I I would like to
see us hang around here you know not for
20 minutes with negative Delta but if
you hang around here for an hour two
hours you know with mostly negative
Delta then yeah I'd be bearish so we
continue higher nice strong aggressive
buying coming in 2,000 2,000
4,000 got the Stacked imbalance here and
we come all the way up to these highs up
here at 88 and a half you got a ra
Divergence no ratio but next bar you've
got the ratio okay and then what happens
now up here it's 1114 negative Delta
negative Delta negative Delta getting
stronger you know 1,700 3,800 then you
sort of trade Deltas here positive
positive negative negative um negative
sorry positive and the negative
now this is this is a signal I talk
about every single video you know you
have your Divergence and your ratio and
then the market sells off um again you
know if you're looking at the
Delta is is it slanted more towards
positive or negative I honestly I think
think it's slanted more towards negative
okay say you're not not convinced on
this Delta look at the bars what do you
have where's your buying imbalances now
instead all you have is selling IM
balances right you on the way up you got
buying IM balances okay well now you hit
this high you're starting to come off
where's your buying imbalances they're
not there instead all you got are
selling imbalances then the market
starts to sell off you know you get the
Trump um you know the Trump remarks
Market uh actually comes down later
makes these new lows down here
boom um you got a Divergence no ratio
you got a ratio on the next bar um you
know shortlived forelli over the next
bar only then it comes back
down um you get down here you start
getting the Delta you know here this I
thought this bar was was bullish you
know point of control right on the
bottom you got a A bullish ratio next
bar you got a ratio um Delta scoer
doesn't happen just goes sideways before
stopping you out then you get um this
load Delta scalper right off the low you
get a little bit of a rally into the
cash
close and you know it sort of puts us
where we are now just a little bit lower
right
now but really the most obvious trade
again was was that uh that high up there
where you have the Divergence and the
ratio again you I talk about those every
day you know that's right on the high of
the day 80 getting short somewhere
around 86 and2 87 you know I'm not
saying that you would have held it all
the way down to to 2:00 where you you're
hitting you know the the lows
whoops you know the the lows the new
lows down here but you know surely you
could have gotten
something decent out of the trade you
know points a few points um you know
from this high at least down to you know
where it comes down in here and just
sort of bounces around so you're talking
from 86 down to
81 you know
okay next I'll talk about uh this is the
mini da the ym is eight range chart now
you mini da and NASDAQ you can you know
they trade around the clock but honestly
you know those are markets that are best
uh best traded during the normal trading
hours when the cash is open so you know
8:30 Chicago time when the the main
underlying stocks are
open you know you just get better volume
I mean there's decent volume you know
earlier but honestly um you're going to
get you know more participation during
the uh during the normal trading hours
so you know 8:30 you know comes in
somewhere in in here these bars now
since then you know your low for the day
was down here at
31 but since the cash open you know your
low is here at 33 and you're coming down
here you know again you even if you're
taking this as your low you know again
you know watch what you happening you
get the Delta scalper here you've got
you know bullish ratios coming in zero
prints which are quite strong and then
the market it rallies it rallies
straight all the way up you know
literally up to the the highs of the day
um you hit your highs around what 10
prob 11:00 um yeah Delta scoper gave a
sell here you know have a ratio and
Divergence didn't work out again you
know up here you had a bunch of negative
Delta honestly I felt the market was
looking a bit heavy maybe it can can
sell off S&P though looked different um
you know then you get your high of the
day up here now you got no you know I'd
love to say oh you got a uh you know
racial endeav you don't have it here you
know in the snps you had it um you know
sometimes you don't get everything that
you want um you know in a market but you
know really you know while the snps you
know were giving you a nice sell signal
yeah I did feel that the the mini da was
giving you you know some nice you know
buying signals down here with the zero
prints with you know the positive Deltas
in here you know right off the low you
know and it rallies up to this area
where you get you know this area here I
honestly I thought this was an area
where the market could sell off and it
it didn't um um at that time so you know
but you you could have caught a decent
move from you know the 40s all the way
up to uh you know the 11 110 area you
know maybe you're looking to get short
here you know you get stopped out up
here but you know are you risking a lot
not really you know you're getting short
somewhere in here you know 105 110 you
know your Stop's just you know right
above 120 so it's you know a 10 thick
stop where you know just now you just
had this move from um 22040 all the way
up to you know basically up to 110 you
know that's was that 60 70 tick move and
then in the next move you're risking
only you know 10 or 15
ticks you know I know I know some people
think oh you know no the order flow has
to give me every single turning point
and every single Turning Point has to be
a a 70 80 tick winner you know it
doesn't work that way honestly it
doesn't um you you still got to manage
trades to a certain extent you know if
if a trade's not working out
you you get out I mean it's simple as
that no one's got a gun to your head
saying you got to hold this position
until goes to your your profit Target or
it uh or it stops you
out now you the next Market I want to
talk about is is crude oil right I did
have a request from someone to talk more
about crude so I'm going I'll try to uh
if I can just find my crude
chart okay
so
crude uh really since uh
so you had this move here in the crude
early this was around 3 in the morning
you this is what it looks like when a
stop gets triggered yesterday's high was
up around here on 72 73 I can't remember
exactly what was the level but I know
that this happened right around the high
and this is what it looks like right
boom you get something gets triggered
everything just gets swept up then
immediately it comes right back down
that's what a stop
induced stacked imbalance looks like all
zeros here and usually in the next bar
it comes right down now does it always
come down no sometimes it keeps going
but generally it will sort of the order
will you know run its course sweep the
book hit this high and then start
selling you know coming back down into
that area now the key is to watch if
this area is going to hold if it doesn't
you know we might go lower you know this
is if you're a scalper you know in the
sense of trading with a dome you know
this this could be a nice opportunity
for you to fade this move up here
because you know it's sort of a a fake
move I say fake move higher but you know
it's an artificial move higher based on
stops being triggered and it's going to
come right back down on you
now later a little bit later you know
that's when I you know it's what I call
weak High I don't like the term we weak
high it's kind of an oxymoron um but you
know every time you hit a high you
should be asking yourself are we going
to keep going higher or are we going to
sell off and what happens is a little
bit later we Circle back up towards this
High we get up you know about four ticks
from that high Delta scalper um kicks in
now you know read the Delta so you know
like I was talking about earlier you
know watching the Delta right so here
this High you do have positive Delta
still in this bar but then negative
Delta negative Delta negative Delta
negative Delta negative Delta negative
Delta negative Delta you're thinking hey
this Market should sell off right and I
I just showed you the minis that you
know it should sell off then what
happens it starts railing okay but watch
it 327 21189 it's getting weaker so
you're getting some buying you know
people are coming in thinking hey you
know let's take this Market higher but
it's getting weaker so you know everyone
say yeah yeah let's go higher let's go
higher so everyone's piling in but then
we start ticking a little bit higher
towards our highs and less aggressive
buying you get up to this bar 89 only
bar is Red Bar turns down next bar boom
negative Delta Delta scalper kicks Inus
600 and honestly at this point I felt it
was lights out already because yeah you
have this little spat of buying you know
sort of a bounce in here but then the
negative Delta is is showing its
strength here here um you should have
been convinced already but if you uh if
you weren't okay you know maybe you want
a little more confirmation I don't know
what other the sort of confirmation you
need but you know what happens from this
Market you're trading you know somewhere
around here 49 I don't call it 49 I'm
not even going to call it in this bar
I'll just say this bar you know 49
63 and boom boom you know just consider
keep making our ways lower lower lower
lower lower no reason to be buying
anywhere in
here coming down towards our low here at
uh our low at this point was what
18 do bounce up a little bit come back
up again any reason to really be buying
down here no no not at all um making new
lows making new lows I'm not saying you
you would have sold it there at 4: in
the morning and held it all the way till
8:00 in the morning but honestly there
was there was no reason to be buying it
covering your I mean you can cover your
short if you have a Target but
uh there just wasn't any major reason
now you get down in here you got this
this push here at 825 very strong
negative Delta basically the whole bar
is basically
imbalances um next bar comes right back
and then even this bar boom comes right
back got the Delta scalper given a buy
just go sideways sideways um another
Delta scalper buy that didn't work out
um then you come down into this low
here um you do have a Divergence no r
show no ratio in the next bar you do get
a rally though um which was was quite a
nice
rally um let me see where's the point I
want to talk about so again you know
these red lines this is the price
rejector indicator um just indicating
rejections and prices so you hit up here
come off a little bit make another run
up here make this this high up here
price rejector kicks in um you know I
was telling you prices are being
rejected up here and then you start
selling off selling off you know got the
Stacked imbalance here then you come
down to this area where you
got the Delta scalper kicking off again
you know it's not the low it's it's kind
of a swing low area but look at this
you're getting some very nice positive
Delta 700 here 600 800 here um you know
at this point where you're trading
you're trading around you know 4918 4920
and then we proceed to you know put a
nice move up
you up to uh 20 up to 42 so it's about a
20 tick move but then it changes here
right you have this stack in Balance
here yeah it's Buy in Balance then you
got to stack sell in a balance so
everything's changed the market is
starting to come off and you know this
one is to me this
was very important you know you had this
demand driven Market you know aggressive
buying on the way up all of a sudden
boom it's telling you boom hey we got
aggressive sellers coming in aggressive
sellers are taking control and what
happens is the Market sells off you know
that's what it does right markets
move based on supply and demand um you
know there's no other way to put it and
the easiest way if you want to check
supply and demand is you watch um for
imbalances right that's the easiest way
to to check what's happening with supply
and demand yeah you can check Delta also
but you know visually it's a lot easier
just to check the uh see if you got a
lot of imbalances in one you
know you know keep it simple right it
doesn't need to be more complicated
you're working your way higher what do
you got you got buying imbalances
where's your selling imbalances on this
move they're not there all of a sudden
you know we started turn here started
going lower selling IM balances selling
IM balances selling
imbalances so watch those selling
imbalances okay so this next Market this
is zero currency honestly I I thought we
were going to have kind of a quiet day I
I was I mean obviously it's it was it
was a quiet day right to start out and I
I do know that you do get big moves off
of quiet days right in in the sense it's
like a repping a rubber band around your
finger right you rubber band goes around
and around around gets tighter then you
let it go it takes off just like today
what happened with the new Highs but um
you know really the big numbers are
coming out later this week I think it's
CPI on on Friday and you know just
looking at the activity overnight you
know I I thought it was going to be a
snoozer but I mean you know you never
know what's going to happen in the us uh
with with our president um but
eurocurrency had had been in a tight
range most of the morning you know
during the European session you sort of
have this area down here where you got
the Delta scalper giving a buy you know
around the 2830 level rallies up to the
40 you got Delta scalper giving a sell
then you're just going sideways so
basically you're trading between you
know 42 and and you know what is that 20
you know 25 most of the morning okay you
know that was here this is 250 in the
morning 3:00 you know all the way up
until boom 7 8 o' here you're coming up
to 8:30 we're still in that range um
Delta scul gives this buy I thought hey
maybe now we can start moving but you
know at the same time we got all this
negative Delta hanging over here you
know just taking it you know back to
here you know negative negative negative
it's all negative running along the
bottom finally the market
breaks starts going going lower lower
lower you know any reason to be buying
down here not really um you do have this
Divergence not a ratio I used to use 25
I I don't anymore I use closer to 30 but
again it's just all I mean you're
getting some positive Delta 12 46 48 but
you know you're expecting this bar to be
red uh green not red here more selling
comes in you know on this move down
these were a lot of imbalances here you
got look at all this negative Delta
right even though you get the bounces
with positive uh with bullish ratio
bullish R still negative Delta sellers
are still in control all negative all
negative Delta here you got you know you
got a
small positive Delta you've
got you know a ratio but you know
looking at the numbers it's quite light
you know compared to the previous bars
so to me you even though it's a ratio in
a Divergence you know taking a look at
this bar I know the volume's light 592
compared to everything else you know 2,
1800 1100 you know this is about half of
the volume then again here you know you
get another um point of control right on
the bottom everything but again the
volumes that are involved here are super
light 115 Lots in this bar um that
that's not going to be enough you know
I'm going to want to see the next bar
for some sort of confirmation then you
get down here start to string together a
little bit of positive Delta which is
nice honestly this would be the Delta
surge given a buy here I don't have it
on this chart didn't work out um he's
still making new lows you know it's
still dominated look at this Delta still
dominated by um
selling you get the Delta scoper given a
buy Here didn't work
out you did get a move from you know
whatever that is 68 all the way up to 74
before it just turns on
you this time it's only 9 you know we
spent the first six hours of the morning
you know from 2:00 a.m. until 700
a.m. you know in a 20 point range all of
a sudden now you know things are going
hey why are here you
get ratio sorry Divergence and a ratio
and then next bar you got the Delta
scalper comes back down tests the low
you know this one didn't stop you out
you get a nice little move up finally
you get some sort of decent move up um
you know 60 you know this is whatever
this is you know 63 64 all the way up to
74 Delta scoper gives a sell
here um you're not getting the big
monster move lower like you were getting
earlier but you know from 67 finally it
starts to sell off you know down below
uh below 50 so that was a decent move
move Delta scer comes in gives you a
nice buy here here you don't have a here
you got Divergence but no ratio you have
Delta scoper giving you a buy this Delta
scop or sell doesn't work
out this another one that
failed excuse me I'm getting my throat
is dry here um then you'll come up up
here around
1240 Delta scoper gives this little bit
of a sell here and you're talking to
move from 86 down into the 70s down down
down
so you know there were some nice moves
to be had here in the euro currency I
said you know honestly looking at this
euro currency chart in the morning I I
felt it was a bit of a snoozer um I
wasn't disappointed by um the way the
market unfolded during the
day so next I'll talk about the Delta
scalper really quick
um yeah it's it's
interesting okay when you just really
quick this is
I'm going to show you guys the the user
guide uh really
quick yeah for some reason I I don't
know people are busy you they're excited
you know with the new indicator and you
know they want to put it on so this is
the user guide when you you updated last
month a couple weeks ago um boom boom
boom
so it gets down in here talks about the
settings it's cly stated once you import
the indicator in ninja
Trader you need to open
right
um it's a real-time indicator and it
reads the Delta as it comes into the
market will not work on historical chart
right you could run it in in replay mode
ninja Trader replay mode to see how it
worked on the previous data but you
you're not going to open your
chart and it's going to just you know
backfill all all the data right like uh
for example here right this is the
crude okay so my charts have been open
you know
since uh you know since yesterday so
since last night so you know i' I've got
the signals in here right these are
that's a nice move here it's a nice move
up those are those moves I talked about
but you know the previous day's data
it's not going to appear right because
it's reading the data as it comes in so
you know don't expect it don't think I'm
going to load it up and I'm going to see
every time it should have plotted no it
doesn't work that way yeah I'm very
clear in the uh in the instructions you
know I'm just talking about it because I
had it back and forth with
somebody who obviously didn't understand
that and you know it was kind of um kind
of frustrating honestly but you know on
on you on the silver lining out of
everything again I don't think I would
use it but you know he was telling me Oh
I use it on you know cuz what he done
right is you he trades a a crude oil he
trades he likes to look on crude at 233
tick chart so he just opened up his
ninja Trader installed the indicator
didn't restart ninja Trader which you
know every time you install an indicator
on ninja Trader you should restart ninja
Trader okay for it to to work properly
otherwise you're going to get a specific
popup that says it's not licensed and
it's a very specific popup that only
pops up when you install an indicator
and then when you try to run it without
restarting ninja
Trader um so you know anytime you
install anything on your computer right
you should restart your computer you
know and same thing goes with Ninja
Trader anytime you install an additional
indicator on ninja Trader restart your
ninja Trader I see you know I I think a
233 tick chart is a bit tight maybe you
know in the mornings you know when
you're not getting you know all the
volatility you can probably trade it but
honestly I was quite surprised at the
signals I was getting now this guy was
saying he's getting no signals well
that's because he didn't follow the
instructions but you know you get nice
moves here you get a little down moves
here you know if if you're a scalper
right if if you're looking for you know
quick hits and and I know people that
like to trade that way just looking for
quick hits honestly I was very my eyes
are like popping open like wow um you
know you look at this stuff getting some
very nice signals I mean yeah do does is
every trade a winner no but you know if
you're in it for quick in and
outs you know it's it's pretty pretty
good you know I mean you know for a lot
of Traders you know they sort of have
this Dome trading mentality they're just
looking for the next few ticks they're
not looking for the the big moves you
know if
the Dome traders that I know you know
they just like I said you know they're
looking for the next three to five ticks
and you know you get three to five ticks
you know me personally I like to get the
moves like this the next uh 10 20 ticks
rather than the next three and five
ticks but you know if you're looking for
the next three to five ticks you know
this is something that I think that can
help a lot of people now is it right
every time no this one I I don't think
you would have got you know what the
move you wanted or this one but then
you're getting it here you know you're
getting it here you're getting it here
you're getting something
here you here you run into a bit rough
rough patch here boom boom boom well
fail fail fail but then boom it comes
right back up you know another one I
don't think you would have got the five
ticks that you wanted here who knows you
know maybe you're buying it here selling
it somewhere up in here depends you know
what your what Your targets are so you
know this is the the 233 tick chart now
you know so the other chart then he
telling me also um NASDAQ honestly
NASDAQ on a 233 tick chart again you
know I'm not convinced that it's
something that I would want to trade but
you know maybe for some of you guys that
are you
know Shooters you know quick guns you
know you might want to consider it
honestly I I don't really like it I
think it's just too fast um you know
that's my own personal
taste but you know you are getting some
decent moves I mean yeah you get some
stopouts like here you know this one's
not really going anywhere but then you
get it follows up with a decent winner
follows up decent winner decent winner
here again it's you're trading a two 33
tick chart you should have very
um I want to say tight profit targets
but again you know you're not going to
trade a 233 tick chart and get short you
know here at 11:15 and hold it until 12
no you're you're in and out you're in
and out that's why you're using such a
um short range chart I mean yeah you
would love to get a move like this get
short here and get out down here but you
know honestly that's not how you should
be trading A 233 tick I mean you could
you could but honestly you know people
that I know that would trade a chart
like that are really just in and out in
and out um very very quick and you know
the other
chart the other chart is is four range
mini da which again you know honestly I
think is a bit tight I I honestly I
prefer an eight range um minow
chart
but you know as it look you know since
again you know I always say you know
mini da and NASDAQ is something best
traded during the cash open so Cash open
is here you get this nice immediate move
up here this one doesn't work out get a
nice little move here you know you're
trailing your stop it starts coming down
you know you're out here this one
doesn't work out this one doesn't work
out not really you know this area run
into some troubles down there so you
know honestly I don't think a for range
mini Dow chart is going to be very
effective honestly um I I think a
uh you know an eight range mini Dow
chart would be much better let me see I
think I've got one
here surely I I know I usually keep one
open let me just dig it out
here next next
t uh
surprisingly surprisingly I can't find
it here just bear with
me no huh strange I I don't have one
open um I've got one open but I'm
running something else on it not the uh
Delta
scalper I mean well anyway this is okay
well just this is an eight range mini
Dow chart but it's footprint chart okay
but you know again you know this is the
move I talked about earlier from 22 uh
you know here
2240 you know all the way up to uh you
know that was a nice move up here to you
know the 110
area then you had that cell that didn't
work out okay fair enough didn't work
out start coming off no other signals at
this
point so you had one buy you had one
sell here you got another Buy this was
uh just before the cash a little bit of
a move here another buy here um you know
a little bit of a move there so you know
on an eight range chart I think it's
better than a four range chart in the
mini Dow but that's just me you know I
don't want you know oh Mike says you
have to trade it this way no um you know
find something you're comfortable with
it depends on your um your your trading
style you know for
example uh where is that chart here I'll
show you a fast chart you know I do like
to keep it open is
this here
you you know this is the uh mini da this
is 100 tick chart you know here I just
said you know I think uh a you know four
range is fast you know a 100 tick chart
is is also fast but you're getting some
nice buys here boom boom boom you know
here's a sell doesn't work out here's a
buy yeah maybe stopped out then here you
get the nice move up getting some cells
here a little bit of move here a little
bit of a move
there um these are kind of
mixed think a nice little sell here this
one doesn't work out this
buy um you a little of a move
here not really not really get a buy
down here rallies up another rally here
you know short lived rally you know
trailing your stop you know maybe you're
breaking
even so you know how do how it really
comes down to you know what type of
uh what type of Market you're trading
you know and and what you're comfortable
with in terms of you know the amount of
Trades you're going to be taking you
know like you I could show you this
right I I could sit here and say hey Pat
myself on the back look I picked the
high with the Delta scalper it's a f
minute chart e
minis it's got the high there it's boom
you know you hit the high Delta scoper
kicks off there
2486 and you know we trade down to
24 you know down to new lows down here
but you know you know this is the move
you know that Traders dream of you know
but I'll still get nasty emails from
people saying oh you know you had this
losing trade here or this one stopped me
out and I missed this move then I missed
this move you know stopped me out so I
didn't take this trade well I mean what
are you doing if if that's the case
right well you know every trading book I
I read says stop trading after three
losers you know they had this you know
here earlier 6:00 there was a trade here
that this was a nice little winner but
you know so you know I had two losers I
didn't want to have another loser so I
stopped trading you know that sort of
mentality to me is wrong right instead
of stop trading you know if if you have
confidence in yourself and know what
you're doing instead of stopping yeah I
understand the psychology of it okay
believe me I understand it um reduce
your tick side or your lot size you know
instead of trading five Lots go down to
two lots go down to one lot you know
one's got a gun to your head that says
you have to trade your full account um
you know or your max position at any
time you know really what you want to do
is get yourself um you know back on on
the winning track mentally right
mental uh your mental uh stability plays
a big role in in your trading success
you know not a lot of people understand
that they think oh no I just have to
have the perfect indicator well doesn't
matter you have the perfect indicator
but you know if if you can't handle
taking a loss here and there it's it's
going to affect your trading you know
again you know if you take this one say
you get stopped out here stopped out
here and you're thinking oh I I want to
take this next trade cuz it's going to
some get stopped out and take another
loss you know then all of a sudden you
know I went from um you know buying a
nice car here okay I I've minimized my
thoughts maybe I just take the family on
vacation now the vacation's out the
window I don't want to take this cuz you
know I want to eat tonight and then all
of a sudden boom you know you miss that
move so you know you got to you know
take stock of your Mental Cap abilities
and you know how you want to trade I
mean you know I could show you nice
charts like this all day long you know
we it's just picking nice moves but you
know that that's not what it's about you
know I don't want people thinking every
move is going to be like this no you
know they do happen but you know not
every single move is going to be right
on the right off the high and sell off
right into new lows right so lastly I'll
talk about this uh Japanese y chart I'll
try and minimize some of this stuff a
little bit so get it's a 15-minute chart
okay you know people ask you know hey
can I trade it on a longer term chart
honestly about 15 minutes is about as
far out as I go um with the orderflow
chart so you coming up here you got a
ratio and Divergence Delta scalper point
of control right on the top it's all
systems go get short what happens is
come back up here make a new high
unfortunately but then again you know
you've got everything sort of lining up
again you got a Divergence got point of
control up near the top of the Long Bar
that's why I'm not big necessarily a big
fan of uh minute base charts is cuz got
this 15-minute chart you know you got
this bar here it's got such a big bar
the next bar is Tiny you know um it can
vary like that I prefer to watch how the
markets move rather than you know
letting time tell me that it's time to
form a new bar but anyway you know you
get stopped out on this trade then you
got it again here Delta scalper you got
the Divergence ratio is close but next
bar is got the bearish ratio okay so
again it's it's telling you hey you you
should be looking to get short here then
boom it sells off um you know from your
High down into your lows so then you
know does make a does start to make a
move back up but again you know can you
use orderflow on on longer term charts
yeah you can you don't get as many um
trading
opportunities but you know you're still
looking at the same thing whether you're
looking at a one minute chart uh you
know a 15-minute chart or an eight range
chart the the same
Concepts the same Concepts
apply so
um you you don't have to change your
trading style or anything like that you
just you know use your
existing style of trading you know look
for the same things in the market so you
anyway this video has gone on quite
long you know to learn more about
orderflow visit my website orderflows
dcom or visit Deltas scalper if you're
interested in the Delta scalper um you
know it's a great little tool for um
Traders I've been getting a lot of
people telling me very nice things about
it I don't want to get into percentages
cuz you don't eat percentages but um you
know people are sharing with me uh their
charts and you know how well it's it's
performing for them so thanks for
watching this and bye-bye